vous pourrez suivre en direct le
discours de françois fillon le premier
ministre qui va s'exprimer sur la mort
d'oussama ben laden
le premier ministre est en ce moment en
déplacement dans le rhône un déplacement
sur le thème de la sécurité il a visité
un commissariat de police en début
d'après-midi pour l'instant l'exécutif
français n'a pas réagi à cette nouvelle
donc à la mort d'oussama ben laden
nouvelle qui nous est parvenu ce matin
depuis les états unis on écoute donc le
premier ministre pour cette première
réaction il est en direct d'ecully en
banlieue lyonnaise pour les terroristes
dont l'armé est le mépris de la vie il
n'y a ni refuge ni impunité
elle nous encourage à continuer nos
efforts contre tous ceux qui visent des
innocents et qu'ils veulent imposer leur
loi par la terreur un moment où un vent
de démocratie souffle sur les pays
arabes
nous devons rappeler que les musulmans
sont les premières victimes de ceux qui
se réclament d'oussama ben laden une
étape vient d'être franchie
mais le combat contre le terrorisme n'en
est pas pour autant terminé et notre
vigilance doit être renforcée
la france qui paie un lourd tribut à
cette lutte par le nombre de ses soldats
tués ou blessés en afghanistan et par le
nombre de ses ressortissants pris en
otage dans diverses parties du monde où
agissent justement des émules d'oussama
ben laden
la france continuera à se battre pour le
respect de la vie humaine pour la paix
et pour la démocratie
mesdames et messieurs j'ai voulu avec le
ministre de l'intérieur claude guéant ce
déplacement à ecully pour rendre hommage
au travail de la police technique et
scientifique et pour dire aux français
que leur sécurité demeure une priorité
du gouvernement
ce n'est pas une priorité partisane ça
n'est pas une priorité d'un jour
c'est une priorité quotidienne qui
commande de la continuité et de la
ténacité
chaque jour en matière de lutte contre
l'insécurité est un combat et c'est
toute la chaîne qui garantit la
tranquillité publique qui doit être
mobilisé la dissuasion la répression la
sanction la prévention l'éducation ce
sont tous ces maillons qui doivent
former une digue légale et morale face à
la violence les policiers les gendarmes
sont en première ligne
mais je veux dire que c'est toute notre
société qui doit se sentir responsable
et qui doit se sentir mobiliser face à
ces dérives les plus sombres la volonté
de nicolas sarkozy ministre de
l'intérieur puis président de la
république a permis d'engager une lutte
à armes égales
en donnant à la police et à la
gendarmerie nationale les moyens de
traquer la délinquance et de s'attaquer
à toutes ses formes depuis 2007 l'action
des policiers et des gendarmes
votre action porte ses fruits la
délinquance qui avaient augmenté
fortement avant 2002 a diminué de plus
de 16% depuis cette date le taux
d'élucidation qui était en 2002 de 26%
est aujourd'hui de 34% sur cette même
période les infractions révélées par
l'action des services ont augmenté de
plus de 40% ce qui confirme l'engagement
sans faille de nos forces de sécurité
pour ne prendre qu'un exemple le nombre
de cambriolages entre 2002 et avril 2011
a baissé de 32% et l'élucidation de ces
cambriolages a progressé de plus d'un
tiers
l'apport de la police technique et
scientifique qui est évidemment et on
vient de le voir tout au long de cette
visite passionnante pour beaucoup ces
chiffres ne signifient pas que le combat
est gagné
mais après des années de dégradation
nul ne peut sérieusement contesté les
résultats des dix dernières années et
ces résultats ne sont pas le fruit du
hasard
ce qui a changé depuis 2002 c'est
d'abord notre doctrine la présence de
policiers ou de gendarmes au seul genre
de service
sans prise en compte des mutations de la
délinquance c'est une situation qui
appartient au passé
nous lui avons substitué une conception
réactive et volontariste de la sécurité
qui implique d'analyser les formes de la
délinquance d'identifier les réseaux
d'encourager l'initiative de mesurer les
résultats pour les améliorer et pour
agir avec plus d'efficacité
cette action déterminée qui est
aujourd'hui pilotée par claude guéant se
poursuit méthodiquement et en
particulier à travers les sept plans
d'action qui ont été élaborées et
appliquées depuis 2010 pour lutter
contre les cambriolages contre les
violences scolaires contre les bandes
contre les hooligans contre les trafics
de sus de stupéfiants contre
l'insécurité dans les transports contre
les atteintes aux personnes âgées
ce qui a changé c'est aussi la qualité
renforcée des moyens d'action des
policiers et les gendarmes
depuis 2002 la police technique et
scientifique a été sollicité comme
jamais elle a apporté un soutien
inestimable à l'élucidation des affaires
elle a fait l'objet d'investissements
très importants et des moyens
supplémentaires ont été alloués à la
modernisation de ses outils qu'ils
s'agissent des grands fichiers
d'identification et de procédures du
relevé de la numérisation des empreintes
de l'analyse des données informatiques
et de téléphonie mobile en quatre ans
les effectifs des personnels
scientifiques de la dgpn ont progressé
de plus de 30% et le nombre des
policiers dédiés à la police technique
et scientifique a progressé de près de
6% grâce à tous ces efforts la police
technique et scientifique n'est plus
réservé aux grandes affaires criminelles
nous avons démocratiser cette technique
pour la mettre au service de toutes les
victimes pour permettre de mieux lutter
contre la délinquance du quotidien qui
est fait d'agression de vol de
cambriolage enfin ce qui a changé c'est
la confiance placée dans les femmes et
les hommes qui s'investissent dans la
lutte contre la délinquance
je me souvient d'un temps pas si anciens
où les forces de l'ordre et leur
autorité était parfois dénigrer
caricature est déconsidéré
cette injustice a été réparée et chacun
désormais mesure le prix de la sécurité
sans laquelle il n'y a pas de liberté
et chacun sait que chaque policier
chaque gendarme représente une part de
la république dans laquelle il 5 1 un
plan sans précédent de recrutement de
qualification de professionnalisation a
été menée pour la police à partir de
2004 le protocole des cordes carrière
avec ces aménagements successifs la
requalification des officiers de police
de catégorie à celle des gradés et
gardiens en catégorie b l'extension de
la réforme aux gendarmes
la définition du rôle de conception et
de direction des commissaires de police
la reconnaissance du rôle d'encadrement
des officiers tout cela a profondément
modifié la physionomie des forces de
sécurité dans notre pays
la police nationale et la gendarmerie
sont plus modernes elles sont plus
réactive
elles ne sont plus ce qu'elles étaient
il ya dix ans notre sécurité n'est plus
assurée par des cordes d'exécution mais
par des fonctionnaires et des militaires
recrutés et formés pour être
responsables pour prendre des
initiatives dans les enquêtes pour être
à l'écouté des territoires dans lesquels
ils évoluent je veux profiter de
l'occasion qui m'est donnée de
m'adresser à vous pour rendre un hommage
particulier à tous les policiers et à
tous les gendarmes en 2010 et en 2011 27
policiers et gendarmes ont trouvé la
mort au service et beaucoup d'entre eux
ont été blessés dans l'accomplissement
de leur mission
les français ne doivent jamais oublier
que leur sécurité a parfois un prix très
douloureux la cohérence de notre
politique de sécurité
impliqué des évolutions législatives
forte qui puisse prendre en compte en
particulier les évolutions
technologiques
depuis le 15 mars monsieur mise de
l'intérieur la loppsi 2 donne à nos
forces de sécurité des moyens nouveaux
les fichiers de police et de gendarmerie
ont été mis au service de l'élucidation
les opérateurs doivent désormais bloqué
les téléphones portables
ont été volés en ile de france depuis
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi le préfet
de police a déjà ordonné le blocage de
5000 téléphone quant au déploiement de
la vidéoprotection il se poursuit avec
l'objectif de porter à environ 45000 le
nombre des caméras avant la fin de
l'année aujourd'hui nous devons aller
encore plus loin
nous devons aller plus loin parce que
les délinquants ne désarment pas et nous
savons qu'il ne désarmeront jamais c'est
un combat sans fin que nous devons
conduire que nous avons devoir de
conduire parce que la puissance publique
doit en permanence adapter ses ripostes
parce que nos concitoyens attendent de
nous des progrès constants et des
progrès qu'ils soient toujours plus
tangible et ils ont raison d'être
exigeants peu importe les statistiques
si au fond nos concitoyens ressentent
l'insécurité
nous ne prenons pas une politique du
chiffre comme je l'entends si souvent
critiqué mais une politique du résultat
au delà de notre bilan nous avons le
devoir de convaincre et de rassurer dans
les quartiers dans les cités dans les
campagnes et pour cela je voudrais cet
après midi devant vous fixé plusieurs
lignes d'action d'abord nous devons
prendre en compte les attentes de la
population qui souhaite une police plus
présente et plus visibles sur la voie
publique
c'est tout le sens de l'instauration des
patrouilleurs que claude guéant va
déployer dans les zones urbaines la
présence accrue des policiers sur la
voie publique est une réponse parmi
d'autres à certaines formes de
délinquance elle complète le travail
d'investigation de fond mené par les
brigades spécialisées ces patrouilleurs
contribueront à renforcer les contacts
et le lien de confiance avec la
population mais dans le cadre d'une
affirmation claire de leur autorité et
du coeur de leur mission
c'est à dire l'application des lois et
le maintien de l'ordre public
bien connaître le terrain connaître ce
qu'ils vivent
il est reconnu par eux c'est évidemment
très important pour accomplir ses
missions mais ce lien est une condition
de l'application des lois il ne doit pas
conduire à substituer la convivialité à
l'autorité comme on pouvait le voir dans
la philosophie et dans la pratique de la
police de proximité pour créer ce lien
il faut du temps il faut fidéliser
davantage certains policiers dans les
quartiers
il faut aussi que les policiers
s'investissent dans la sécurité du
quotidien contre les faits de petite
délinquance contre les incivilités qui
exaspère les français que ce soit
l'occupation illicite des halls d'entrée
d'immeubles la mendicité agressive ou
usage de motos ou de cyclomoteurs
débridés
en deuxième lieu il faut revoir les
fondamentaux de notre politique pénale
michel mercier s'y emploie avec
résolution et avec un sens du dialogue
tout à fait lyonnais nous vivons
actuellement une réforme importante je
veux parler de celle de la garde à vue
je sais que c'est une réforme qui
inquiète les enquêteurs et je veux dire
que je peux comprendre certaines de
leurs appréhensions parce qu'il s'agit
d'une évolution brutale de la conduite
de l'investigation
une évolution qui vous le savez nous est
imposée par des décisions du conseil
constitutionnel et de la cour de
cassation
elle implique un changement des
modalités de l'interrogatoire des
stratégies de l'enquète de la recherche
de la preuve
l'aveu ne peut plus être la seule
solution à toute enquête son statut de
preuve
à elles seules déterminante et
irréfutables a vécu même si son
importance dans le déroulement de
l'enquète et dans l'analyse des charges
restera évidente
nous évoluons vers un système dans
lequel la preuve matérielle devient
essentielle et c'est pour cela que tous
les investissements réalisés dans la
police scientifique et technique sont
tellement importants aujourd'hui j'ai
confiance dans la capacité des policiers
et des gendarmes à faire évoluer leur
mode d'intervention et leur savoir faire
professionnel pour s'adapter à cette
réforme qui était de
inévitable et je veux dire que je serai
très attentif aux résultats et aux
recommandations de l'audit que j'ai
demandé à michel mercier et à claude
guéant pour évaluer l'impact des
nouvelles dispositions et le cas échéant
si cela était nécessaire les aménager
mais nous ne devons pas en rester à
cette seule question de la réforme de la
garde à vue
la garde à vue ça n'est qu'un élément
d'une réformes beaucoup plus ambitieuses
qui est la réforme globale de la
procédure pénale
bien sûr nous avons dû anticiper la mise
en oeuvre de la réforme de la garde à
vue pour nous mais pour éviter de nous
mettre dans une situation
d'inconstitutionnalité
mais dans les prochaines années la
réforme globale de la procédure pénale
sera plus que jamais d'actualité et les
professionnels de l'enquète que sont les
officiers de police judiciaire doivent y
être très étroitement associés j'attache
également beaucoup d'importance au bon
fonctionnement de la chaîne pénale
trop de peines prononcées par les
tribunaux sont exécutés tardivement nous
avons commencé à nous attaquer à ce
problème avec des résultats
encourageants et nous allons continuer à
le faire
notre objectif c'est aussi de mettre fin
aux agissements d'un petit nombre de
multiréitérants malheureusement souvent
mineurs c'est aujourd'hui la mission qui
revient aux états-majors de sécurité qui
sont présidées par les préfets et par
les procureurs que nous avons mis en
place il y a un an et demi qu'ils
doivent maintenant donner pleinement
leur mesure
la lutte contre la délinquance n'est pas
seulement le fait des forces de sécurité
et de justice
elle s'appuie sur le terrain sur toute
une chaîne d'acteurs dont l'engagement
mérite la plus grande considération
c'est la raison pour laquelle en
troisième lieu je veux que nous
continuons à promouvoir le rôle des élus
dans la sécurité des français parce que
leur connaissance des quartiers et les
habitants en font des acteurs et des
interlocuteurs incontournables
la loi de mars 2007 place le maire au
centre du dispositif comme animateur et
coordinateur de la prévention de la
délinquance
eh bien il faut que nous soyons en
mesure de mieux faire appliquer cette
loi et je souhaite pour cela que nous
diffusions l'exemple des actions qui
partout sur le territoire ont donné des
bons résultats
elles peuvent changer de manière
décisive la physionomie d'un quartier et
améliorer la qualité de la vie j'avais
décidé fin 2009 la création d'une
mission nationale d'évaluation de la
prévention et de la délinquance
plusieurs rapports parlementaires
viennent de m'être remis
nous allons en tirer toutes les
conséquences enfin il faut utiliser à
plein le formidable potentiel humain
dont nous disposons au sein de nos
forces de sécurité
le temps des plans nationaux rigide qui
tombent comme des instructions valable
sur tout le territoire pour toutes les
régions les zones urbaines comme les
territoires ruraux et bien ce temps là
est révolu
les commissaires et les officiers de
police
les officiers de gendarmerie chacun dans
leur département dans leurs
circonscriptions où dans leur brigade
savent mieux que quiconque ou et
l'adversaire et comment le trac je
demande donc une plus grande place soit
donnée dans nos dispositifs de lutte à
l'initiative et à la responsabilité
locale
il faut davantage s'appuyer sur
l'expertisé sur l'expérience de terrain
des policiers et des gendarmes
il faut sortir d'une stricte logique de
décompte de l'activité des services pour
préserver une logique de résultat est
pour moi le résultat c'est une notion
très simple c'est la capacité de nos
services de sécurité à faire reculer les
formes de délinquance qu'ils ont
identifiées dans leur secteur d'activité
c'est aussi évidemment les témoignages
de satisfaction qu'ils reçoivent de la
part de nos concitoyens la délinquance
émouvante elle est évolutive
les policiers et les gendarmes avec
l'aide du puissant appareil de recherche
et d'expertisé a porté par la police
scientifique améliore sans cesse la
qualité de
la riposte et l'élucidation pour
accomplir leur mission ils ont une
capacité d'initiative et d'intervention
sans précédent je voulais vous dire
cet après midi que si la police et la
gendarmerie ont le soutien de la
population
s'ils ont le soutien du président de la
république et du gouvernement ils ont
aussi je veux vous le dire toute notre
confiance et toute notre estime